- Y'all have never met before?
- Yeah.
- No.
- We're bringing.
- Did you say yes?
- people together.
- I said yes, yeah.
We have, five times.
- No, no, we haven't.
- No, no, we've never met.
(Kelly laughing)
- But I didn't know, post COVID,
I don't know whether
to, in these situations,
are you supposed to fist
bump or snog each other?
I just don't know what to do.
- I totally go in for a hug.
- Oh, snogging is nice.
(laughing)
- Is snogging a kiss?
- Yes, snog's a,
- Oh, okay.
- snog's a British kiss,
you know.
- Snog,
- French kiss.
why do y'all call it snog?
Cuz it sounds like,
not hot like a kiss.
- Sounds something repulsive.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's true, I don't know
what the derivation is.
- Interesting. I'm gonna Google that,
if I only there were a way.
Well, congrats on "The White Lotus."
- Thank you.
- Yes.
- That's so,
so very cool.
(audience applauding)
So, and did I hear this right?
You shoot this, it's all shot on the,
is it the coast of Italy?
- It's Sicily, yeah.
Yeah, all, it was...
- Aw.
- Saint Helen.
- Yeah.
- What a job.
- It was a tough one.
- Yeah.
- It was really like, "Oh,
God, this sucks, this is hard."
- That's incredible, yeah.
- Yeah, it was fun.
And we were there for about six months,
you know, cuz-
- Poor you.
- Yeah.
- It was just, "Oh God,"
- "it's really being pushed
through the wringer."
(both laughing)
- It's like where you go on vacation,
but that's kind of funny,
cuz "White Lotus" in general, yeah.
- It's about there, exactly.
- Yeah.
Tell everybody that hasn't seen it,
what is kind of the concept?
- It's kind of a dissection
of how terrible the ultra wealthy can be
in these kind of very bespoke holiday,
you know, holidays.
But it's also, but this one particularly,
is at a section of,
of sexual politics and gender
and,
stereotypes that gender roles have
and kind of dissecting them.
It's really interesting,
but beyond that, it's
quite a dark comedy, so.
- Dude, it's so huge.
I don't know anybody
that doesn't watch the show.
- Did you see the first one?
- Yeah.
- It's a crazy show.
- It actually is fun, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So wait, what's the worst
vacation you've been on?
- Oh, God.
- Just talking about vacation.
- Yeah, I have some terrible ones
of those as well.
- You do?
- Yeah, I think the worst one I got,
I was, you know, in my mid twenties
and I was backpacking around
and my sandals that I had,
kind of disintegrated,
but I wanted to be,
barefoot.
I thought I was kind of
a real hardcore traveler.
Anyway, I picked something up in my foot,
which was a small parasitic worm
and months later,
- Yes.
cuz it takes a while to
just, you know, gestate.
And months later I felt these track marks
coming up my ankle.
- Oh. Hoo!
- And they would,
- Oh no, oh no.
- they would blister and
I wasn't sure what it was,
so I went to the doctors.
They didn't, you know, the local doctor,
they didn't know what it was.
I went into London to the
tropical medicine department.
They didn't know what it was.
- Are they in your skin?
- They're in my skin.
- No! God!
Oh, God. Oh, God.
(laughing)
Oh, God.
- Yeah.
- Wait, that's so gross.
- And in the day they're dormant, right?
But at night is when they're active.
So, you'd be asleep
and then you'd wake up
- Huh!
- and you'd feel something
- Oh, my God.
- like tracking up your leg,
literally.
(Kelly gagging)
And I remember running down
and going to, getting some cutlery
and being like, "Yeah, ah yeah!"
trying to cut it out.
But you know, you can't,
you're not gonna cut it out.
You have to take drugs for it, so.
- Oh, my God.
Oh, I would be so drugged up.
(all laughing)
I would not, I would
not take kindly to that.
That is horrifying.
- Yeah,
that's pretty bad, right?
What about you?
Any terrible, terrible...
- Can't top that.
(all laughing)
I did get sand mites though,
on a vacation,
- Yeah.
and I was holding my baby,
like, no, you know,
reward goes unpunished.
I was holding my baby up at the time
and I was like, "Oh,
we're enjoying the ocean.
What a beautiful moment."
And then I was like, "Why
are my legs so itchy?"
And then I had sand mites,
which I didn't know were a thing.
- What is that?
- And they live under your skin,
just like what you were saying.
- I didn't know that either.
- Oh.
- Yeah, and then I trapped 'em
with,
nail polish stuff or whatever.
Everybody kept telling me,
- Oh yeah, yeah.
but like I don't even know if it worked,
but they went away.
- Well, it's like when a sea urchin bites
you're supposed to like urinate on it.
To kill it.
- Yeah, I've done that before.
I got bit by a jellyfish once.
They're like, "You gotta a pee."
And I was like, "All right."
(all laughing)
I was like, "Done."
(laughing)
I was like, "I don't want it to hurt."
So, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they hurt.
I don't know if you've ever been stung
by like a jellyfish or anything.
- Yes, I have.
- Okay. Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Have you been
on a horrible vacation?
What's your worst experience?
- Yeah, but mine's
not about like worms in my skin.
It's my boyfriend.
When I was like 25, I went on a,
my first kind of grown
up romantic vacation.
- Yeah.
- Oh. Pressure.
- And we went to Paris,
- Hm.
- and he almost left me there
in front of this restaurant,
cuz I was driving him crazy.
(all laughing)
And I remember thinking, "This is Paris."
Like every time we'd
fight about something,
- Yeah.
- I would just thought,
"You can't fight in Paris, you know."
It just, and then it got worse and worse
and then-
- Yeah, well you can.
You know what?
Show him what the worst is
and it only goes up from there.
- Exactly.
- True.
(Kelly laughing)
- Did you make it through?
Like, did you carry-
- He kept me around.
I mean, yeah, we got home.
(all laughing)
- You kept him around.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- I don't know.
Yeah, he was so,
he was so type A,
- People can-
- and like we're just, you know,
we're creative.
- Creative.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- We're like, "Boog on, "
- Yeah.
- "go and move."
- And he was just so in his head,
he was like a lawyer type.
I hope he's not watching.
(all laughing)
- Weirdly, he's in the audience.
- We're all different. It's okay.